a punk rock isabella a secret room for
louisa and missing magical characters
are just some of the fascinating scenes
and storylines cut from the final
version of encanto yipikai movie lovers
i'm jan and in this video i'm explaining
everything you never got to see in
disney's encanto a few spoilers ahead so
take care
although isabella can conjure beautiful
plants and flowers out of thin air a fun
idea for her which didn't make it into
the movie was the ability to create
animated plant creatures such as these
potato characters the idea was that
there would have been a little potato
family living in the house tending to
crops and decked out in traditional
outfits
isabella was designed with a classic
disney princess look and vibe to reflect
her role as the family's golden child as
the story progresses though she reveals
that being a senorita perfecta isn't
what she really wants and transforms her
look from soft castle shades to bolder
colors however the filmmakers also
considered a punk rock version of
isabella that hinted at an even edgier
vibe in the movie among the expectations
placed on isabella is that she should
marry mariano her picture-perfect male
equivalent but originally her suitor was
going to be someone quite different a
guy from the city called bubo he had a
modern look that contrasted with the
traditional feel of the encanto
villagers and he would have brought a
comedic tone to his scenes with a fish
out of water vibe and dorky personality
another entertaining piece of concept
art which wasn't in the movie is this
humorous moment of isabella imitating
mirabelle with a pair of green glasses
created from her vines although each
family member has a room of their own
reflecting their gift and personality we
never actually got to see inside luisa's
room concept art from the art of encanto
book reveals an early idea for her room
was that it should be made entirely of
stone to reflect her strength and the
fact she's the most responsible person
in the family the overall idea was that
it should look very boring except for a
secret door in the room that only luisa
knew about which led to a theme park
where she could just have fun like a
little kid and escape the pressures of
her family duties some other versions of
our room include various locations set
up as training areas for exercising and
weights for her to practice lifts
unfortunately the closest we got to this
in the film was a snippet of louisa
running on a magical treadmill created
by the casita during the opening song
the family madrigal
although there are plenty of magical
characters in the final film early
concept art reveals a number of deleted
characters we never got to see two
characters who were scrapped from the
script were magical twins amelia and
sophia who were inseparable but during
their 15th birthday celebration they
unleashed blinding auras over their
guests amelia's aura contained all the
beauty the twins had collected inside
since they were born and the crowd fell
in love with her by contrast sofia
released all their ugliness sparking a
feeling and revulsion towards her this
traumatic event drove a wedge between
the sisters that would take decades to
be undone there was also a pool playing
fortune teller character who had a
similar look and tricks the vibe to
camilo and then there was zoe who could
speak to and connect with machines
getting them to repair themselves
whenever they were broken however when
she was asleep or took a siesta the
machines would also shut down and refuse
to work this family portrait also
reveals more deleted characters behind
mirabelle is an angry looking girl
called fuega who has some kind of
firepowers something some fans
speculated honor might have in the
frozen sequel from the art it feels like
fuego's gift of fire was triggered in
some way by her emotions similar to
peppa and her weather powers and in this
version peppa had a twin called letta
who were likely versions of amelia and
sophia who i mentioned earlier there's
also a deleted character called
princessa and it looks like her princess
vibe ended up being merged with
isabella's flower powers standing next
to agostine is a woman named miranda
who's holding a bunny implying she had a
connection to animals similar to antonio
in the final film and given she's by
agustin i think she was the original
version of mirabelle's mother julieta
who has the power to heal injuries with
food there's also another older
character here called raimi in addition
to the grumpy abuela below and there's a
short mischievous looking girl without a
name who wasn't in the final movie
either on top of all that there's a
statue of a woman wielding a sword whose
name is alejandra my guess is that this
stern looking character was the original
matriarch who established the house and
that she was abuela's mother in fact
this fits with the original idea for
encanto which was that the story would
take place over a hundred years through
multiple generations in terms of
engando's time period according to the
filmmakers the final movie has an early
1900s look with a folkloric colombian
aesthetic although initially it was
going to have more of a 1950s look like
these early designs for mirabelle
bruno may be a forbidden word in the
madrigal family but mirabelle's
mysterious uncle was actually originally
going to be named oscar as revealed in
this colour palette for the family
however according to the disney fandom
wiki lim manuel miranda changed the name
to bruno as he wanted it to fit in the
line we don't talk about bruno no no no
given bruno is initially portrayed as
the black sheep of the family it's
amusing that pixar's latest film luca
also had a thing about bruno's your
brother
some early designs for bruno showed him
much younger and his eyes glowed both
green and blue which is a way of playing
around with the idea that he had the
ability to see into the future
another character who changed from her
initial concept is peppa who controls
the weather with her emotions originally
her powers were that she was
indestructible and couldn't get hurt
which made her into something of a
daredevil the problem was that her
indestructibility felt too similar to
luisa's great strength so they decided
to give her weather-related powers
instead which kept the sense of
eccentricity and strangeness they were
looking for in mirabella's aunt
and this version of antonio had him
talking through his animals and paying
them with snacks rather than relaying
what they were saying to him
uh-huh uh-huh i understand you the
teaser trailer for encounter has scenes
which weren't included in the final
movie there's lisa doing weights with a
pair of pianos antonio beckoning them
whistling to call all his animals to him
and isabella swinging down on a vine
outside the house while making flowers
around her i think these scenes were
made specifically for the trailer to
show some of the characters powers
there's also what appears to be a
deleted scene in the teaser trailer of
mirabelle sitting on a wall with one of
antonio's tapers which i think was a
scene cut from just before she goes to
ask luisa about what's wrong with the
family's magic
although the look and design of the
family house was gorgeous there were
also some fascinating alternate designs
in this one the casita was built on top
of some kind of rock formation up in the
mountains the idea was to illustrate how
new rooms would be added onto the house
whenever a new family member received
their gift other early designs had the
house built around the natural rocks and
boulders in the environment and this
version of the house had no straight
lines to give it an even more whimsical
and handmade feel
another idea for the casita that didn't
make it into the final film was that it
was an extension of abuela rather than
the whole family and the colour of the
wallpaper would reflect her mood in
whatever room she was in likewise in
another version of the movie as
mirabelle narrated the story the colours
of the world around her were going to
change according to her emotions then in
the third act the film would have
switched to show everything from
abuela's point of view with things now
looking more realistic and photographic
according to one of the movie's
production designers that idea was
rejected as they thought it was too
distracting
in another rejected storyline agostine
was the family patriarch who originally
built the madrigal house in that version
rather than being julieta's husband
agustine was a strong-willed character
who already had a moustache at the age
of four he was warned by a mysterious
woman against building a house in the
encounter but after he ignored her the
house room out the window in encanto the
characters never leave the town so only
the magical doors and rooms allow them
an opportunity to explore other
environments however in an earlier
version of the story mirabel went with
abuela to the city the old woman
originally came from during the visit
they would have seen technology not
available in the isolated encanto
including the traditional chiva
colourful buses often considered symbols
of colombia and if you want to check out
more of the gorgeous concept art from
encanto consider getting a copy of the
art of encanto book i've added links in
the description on how you can get the
book with free worldwide shipping so
what do you think of encanto and do you
wish any of these ideas had been in the
final movie let me know in the comments
below if you enjoyed this then do like
and share this video i really appreciate
it and next you can tap left to discover
the top 50 easter eggs and incredible
details you might have missed and
encanto thanks for watching and see you
next time yupikai movie lovers